success in the fight against the
coronavirus may depend in part on two
things learning who has the disease and
who could get it
health officials use a method called
contact tracing to find out who infected
patients may have met our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is in New
York Jericka how is this effort being
stepped up well good morning to you
Anthony
what's happening right now is that we're
seeing city county and state health
departments that are coordinating this
effort but what we're also seeing is
that these health departments are
actually expanding their rosters of
traceurs this happening at the same time
that some of the world's biggest tech
companies are helping what d-did you
start to feel like you have some kind of
symptoms in Salt Lake County which has
more than half of Utah's three
thousand-plus Kovach cases they're
aggressively stepping up contact tracing
we know it's important to not just know
who the positive case is but who in an
infectious disease they have been in
contact with Gary Edwards is executive
director of Salt Lake County Health
Department are you testing the people in
that house as well when you identify
someone who has tested positive for
Kovan 19 if it is a household we do want
those family members tested yes because
that has been especially close contact
in contact tracing a person who tests
positive tells the Health Department who
they've been in contact with the health
department then alerts those people and
asked them to monitor their symptoms and
to quarantine if needed and it's
happening across the country I asked you
all to start keeping a daily log Rhode
Island's governor asked everyone in the
state to keep a personal log of whom
they've encountered Massachusetts is
investing 44 million dollars to hire and
train more traceurs so here I have the
least of my contacts and in San
Francisco with more than one thousand
cases and at least 20 deaths health care
officials use text messaging to
communicate with people who tested
positive and their close contacts most
at risk for every new case there are
three to five close contact
dr. Mike Reid is with the San Francisco
Department of Public Health they're
calling on everyone from medical
students to librarians to help them with
contact tracing the reason for training
people now is so that we're ready in
three four five weeks time whenever the
decision is made that will end shelter
in place
tech companies are also preparing apple
and google recently announced a joint
plan to create software for iPhones and
androids that will allow them to keep a
record of every other phone they've come
in close contact with the tracking is
voluntary your phone will know what
other phones you have been here for a
period of time then if you let's say
test positive and you alert the system
it will go and find all of these phones
that you have been near over the last 14
days Dan Ackerman is senior managing
editor for CNN of course there are a lot
of issues with that just because your
phone is within Bluetooth range of
another phone doesn't mean that you were
necessarily in communicable disease
range of somebody Americans love their
apps but they also love their privacy
when we think about tracking and tracing
all the news of less that we use has
been negative and now they're trying to
shift it into being something for a
greater public good it may be a hard
sell
now using a smart phone to trace this
virus is already happening in places
like South Korea and Singapore but there
it is mandatory and something else worth
mentioning Anthony is that these contact
tracers will not ask for information
regarding your social security number
your financial information and they will
not ask about your immigration status
yeah it's a valuable tool Jericka and
we're gonna need two health experts say
we're gonna need a small army of contact
tracers in the weeks ahead Jory good
Duncan thanks